على شفا السقوط تبدو مدينه باخمت العصيه
على القوات الروسيه لسبعه اشهر جبهه داميه
للقوات الاوكرانيه التي يصر قادتها على
عدم التفريط فيها رغم نصائح الحلفاء في
الساعات الاخيره بات الشطر الشرقي للمدينه
في يد ميليشيا فاجنر وصولا الى نهر
ما الذي يرجوه الروس وراء بخمت بحسب
الرئيس الاوكراني ستكون الطريق مفتوحه
للروس باتجاه كل من سلوفيانسك وكراماتورسك
التي تعد عاصمه مقاطعه دونيسك المؤقته
بنسبه للاوكرانيين اي ان السقوط تلك
النقاط سيعني اكتمال سقوط مقاطعه
الروسيه وتلك جبهه شديده الاشتعال فبحسب
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه تصدت قواتها
لاكثر من 100 هجمه على محاور باخموت ولمان
راس الحربه الروسيه في ضخمه هم مقات وكانه
من قبل ساخطين على قياده الجيش الروسي
ويتهمونها بخذلانهم لكن رئيسهم بدا مؤخرا
متصالحا مع وزاره الدفاع في سياق تبشيره
بافق عملياتي اوسع بعد ضخمه
لم يواجه العالم الجيش الروسي المعدى بشكل
جيد ولم يواجه القوات المجهزه باحدث
الاسلحه والتقنيات الاستخباريه التي لم
تدخل المعركه بعد
بالمقابل لا يستهين الاوكرانيون بجبهه
باخموت التي زارها رئيس اركانهم قبل ايام
وفي نفس الوقت يرى الرئيس زلينسكي انما
يقوم به الروس هو البحث عن نصر ولو كان
صغيرا كراماتورز ما تريد روسيا تحقيقه في
انها بحاجه الى انتصار ما حتى لو كان
صغيرا وان تم بتدمير كل شيء في باخموت
وقتل كل مدني هناك
خلال الاشهر الماضيه دعا الحلفاء اوكرانيا
للتخلي عن ضخمه بالنظر لارتفاع كلفه
الدفاع عنها ويبدو انهم ما زالوا عند
رايهم فبحسب وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ليس ثم سوى قيمه رمزيه للمدينه ترجح
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه الميدانيه